[Music]
yeah okay
we carry the zip it instantly I know
patience is the key putting out my [ __ ]
for free this is T we carry feet Michael
make them good morning vaynernation
hope everybody's super well morning
morning morning let's give some
shoutouts Raymond Johannes what's good
Brock Miller what's good Jimmy P in the
building
Jessica Bella Marciano what is up axel
blind hard test Danielle are here would
best be make you show what's up what's
up what's up big shout out to all the
platform's
before we get right into the show let's
share it up really interested in as many
people sharing this as possible if
you're on Facebook absolutely share or
restream if you were on Twitch big shout
out to everybody on Twitch YouTube if
you can just click that URL up there and
share it in facebook or twitter or your
facebook groups or text one homie and
twitter family don't just retweet
retweet retweet let's share this a let's
get some new hearts and minds into this
session we've been helping a lot of
people and I want to get to that place
in the world that's not what's good
what's good with you nothing
not much I just got the twitch alert
which is good you mean the push
notification that I'm live yeah I
appreciate that
I like the sketches we're putting out on
Instagram yeah they remind me of a
little old pick Tamim shirts derived off
of that but yeah those all the like
funny meme kind of things you good yep
awesome
so and um at the end of the show today
we're gonna have a Gary B TV promo thing
just so you know I mean so how about
those Knicks Justin when we do that it's
true I guess we'll we'll throw are we
gonna throw up the Twitter URL to that
so that everybody here
share it yeah how crazy yeah what Dustin
drop the dime on of course it is we've
started something super cool on Twitter
so if you don't follow me on Twitter
you're making a huge mistake doesn't by
the way we need to get like all sorts of
stuff for twitch like where's our team
about so here's the thing in order for
you to like get all those little little
nice things we have to be either an
affiliate or a partner then that would
limit you to not be able to stream other
platforms so it's kind of like a not
sure catch 22 yeah and I think I'm sure
you'd rather be everywhere then
committed so yeah yeah okay I don't I
don't know if that's true I'll figure it
out okay
I mean yeah yeah I'm sure like you can
figure okay cool let's get in the show
the legends in the building
nice to meet you in real pleasure man
I'm about you and your whole crew as you
know we're friendly I'm pretty friendly
with plenty of your fam and it's really
good to see you DJ Paul appreciate all
the work you put in man especially I
appreciate it listen to a lot of your
music Thank You Man thank you I saw I
saw something away a long time ago with
you so my answer I think you might come
in or something or something it was it
was weird I was like wow Ruben I've been
following you for a long time so I
appreciate that man I appreciate you
back way to start let's go what's
cooking
well I got a couple of questions you got
and I don't know if you had time to
answer bow for just whether I do a real
estate on the side outside of music I do
really really go with it and I try to
help out my fans as well so I answer
questions for them so this is a big
question that they always ask me and I
have my answers about it but I wanted to
ask the pro like no thanks one of them
is uh buying versus renting what you
think is best
you know it's really interesting believe
it or not the answer can be either let
me explain obviously when you're buying
your you're creating institutional value
and wealth creation and over the long
period
time that becomes an hour y+ thing
buying real estate has been tried and
true in our society for a hundred years
right and and plus so I'm a fan however
I see a lot of people overextending
themselves on the buy which then takes
their cash out of the equation on other
things of course if you bought a home
ten years ago you would have done well
but if you put that same money into
Amazon stock and just rented you would
have done much better yeah and so people
don't think about options so is buying a
home usually as long as your
neighborhood doesn't go to [ __ ] out of
nowhere and are a Y positive financial
event over time yes doesn't multiply the
same way that if you made a smart
decision at that time with that same
cash no number to most people when they
buy extend themselves too much they buy
the most expensive house they can they
wipe all their liquid on the down
payment and then they kind of live their
life to just make their mortgage
payments and it takes them out of
opportunities you know I bought a lot of
stock during the pandemic the first week
Netflix Amazon they were at like record
lows now a month later than at record
highs later that was an opportunity but
if you didn't have cash to do that
you missed it so the answer is both you
have to be thoughtful on it and you have
to know where you are in your life cycle
and more importantly what are you gonna
do with that cash if you're renting
because just sitting on the cash versus
buying that's not a good idea
yeah cuz a lot of people don't not as
smart as you when it comes to stocks and
win the ban what's about male with
property and especially some of our
mutual fan base if you're in areas that
are on their way up getting gentrified
getting cleaned up you could buy some
homes and places that used to look kind
of dirty yeah you know you can start
buying up those homes on the cheap and
really doing quite well there's a couple
places I'm looking at in Jersey on that
so it listen or you could go buy a house
and what used to seem like a good
neighborhood but then they put some sort
of
change to the highway and it [ __ ] your
[ __ ] up like listen everything's a
gamble to your point DJ Paul is is the
number one thing I want people to do is
buy what they know even though I hate
him because I hate the Bulls with all my
heart I told all my friends I didn't do
it because I had too much emotion but I
told all all my friends to buy Scottie
Pippen rookie cards right uh-huh I'm
gonna pull up the thread actually it's
some crazy [ __ ] I told all my friends to
buy them because I knew this this
documentary was coming right
oh wow yeah so crazy and so that rookie
card went up from 30 from literally from
32 to 300 and you know that's it like
that's 10x on your return and anybody
could have done that if they were paying
attention yeah yeah so better what you
know the next question not my last one
did I get out of here uh
is if you have like I own a lot of
multi-million dollar homes and in big
cities that I rent out and I saw
somebody say that if you have a house
now it's probably the time to sell it
because millenials not gonna be into
homes as much what do you think about
that what I think about that is if
you're renting out those homes you're
gonna win because there is a movement in
the youth to not buy but to rent and
they're still gonna want to live in
fancy places so you're gonna be making
the value on the ownership I I think it
just comes I actually think the renting
market is gonna explode in the premium
market so if you're sitting on that kind
of inventory I actually think you're
sitting well okay I think you're gonna
have more demand I think you're gonna be
able to increase those prices I thought
the same thing too I just didn't know
what security be more an issue and what
they go for condos versus a stand-alone
home no they're plenty are gonna go for
standalone homes because a lot of them
gonna buy into what I'm saying which is
like don't own it
have it five-year where you get caught
the only variable there that can really
get caught
if you go through years of everybody
renting and then one year the market
switches and people go back to buying
homes then you'll need to sell it but I
think you'll make the institutional
value over that time listen good
property is good property always and
forever period whether it's renting or
selling yeah
Piro are all right that we say they keep
doing it
we appreciate it all right let's keep
this going
that was fun hi Gary hey Adriana how are
you good good I feel like this was like
the perfect setup love it because I am a
real estate agent perfect and you guys
were just talking about real estate so
funny as [ __ ] every I'm so first off
thanks for having me on
of course in it so I do have two
questions for you so first question is I
have all the major social media channels
so I have Twitter Linkedin Instagram
tick-tock snapchat I have a whatsapp I
have my website I have everything
because I just opened up my own real
estate office about a year ago so I do a
pretty decent job I guess of posting
content on most of them I've gotten
better for sure since January since I
found that 164 pieces of content
slideshow thing yeah that definitely
helps because I do like a lot of videos
I do a market update video that I post
once a month and I do that kind of been
doing that for like two years so I
started doing more like homeownership
tips like helping define different terms
and stuff like that and they take like a
three minute video and crop it into like
smaller 1 minute section and stuff like
that so that definitely helps my one
thing is as far as growth you know you
always say you know try to comment on
you know blow up on Twitter and comment
on everything with all the different
social media channels that I haven't
been a one-woman show would it be better
for me to give out less time to each one
of them or just pick one at a time for
like a week now I think less time I
think spreading yourself is better
here's why I don't think I think
people's egos are wrapped up in their
following count instead and so they get
caught up in if you focus on one channel
you'd be more likely to get that one
channel to have more followers mm-hmm
and that's what I think people are
aiming for when I'm aiming for his
actual business and by going everywhere
you're tasting different dynamics which
is teaching you how to be a better
creator you don't give a [ __ ] if you
sell a home on tick alpha tick tock or
LinkedIn or YouTube or Facebook you're
in a business most people want to focus
on one thing because their entire
framework when it comes to social media
is completely based on followers right
it's it's it's it's a [ __ ] up thing
that I'm trying to destroy I'm actually
advocating behind the scenes for all
social networks to hide follow account
now and that makes sense
because I do rather than focus on on
that I do tend to focus more on actual
valuable content so I don't really post
a whole lot of stuff of oh I sold this
house or oh oh I sold that house because
I feel like people don't really give a
crap like unless I sold it to them they
don't care I would say here and there
spreading that out isn't bad because it
shows people that you are selling homes
which is fine yeah I think I think your
question is predicated on a social media
question yeah excuse me a social media
perception question versus an actual
business question what if one of your
videos goes viral on tick-tock and that
becomes the thing that most helps your
business that's not something that would
have happened if you most focused on
just getting the most followers you can
on one platform people are absolutely
obsessed with figuring out how to get
followers when what they should be
figuring out is how to get happiness and
how to get the business result they're
looking for and followers are an
indication that you're hitting a nerve
and people are interested but peep but
that's the byproduct not the goal and I
think people are making it the goal and
that's where their strategies are
breaking down that make sense so don't
worry about the followers and learn more
about where my leads are coming from so
to speak and how many hours
crackling flash realizing that you're in
other places that you're learning and
that something may happen somewhere that
you could have never seen and that then
like something may happen on tick-tock
that makes you say oh now tick tock
needs to be 50% of my energy and the
rest need to be 5% each but you would
have never known that if you weren't
giving 5% of your energy to tick tock
Meg's eggs and baskets right okay yeah
eggs and baskets okay and second
question is actually from my husband he
actually is the one that turned me on to
you like four years ago like and I was
one of those people that was like okay
he's a little bit too much money I'm
worried and I actually was one of those
people that thought you were is Nicolas
husband I get it but I was like I feel
like I just at the time was not there
like mentally I get it
so sounds fun yeah we're better um so my
husband though just so I can learn a
little bit was there a piece of content
that kind of triggered it was there any
was there a moment where the switch is
like wait a minute this guy's not full
of [ __ ] this guy actually can help um it
wasn't but it actually wasn't even
wanted George
so I started listening to I'm like a lot
of like Jim Rohn and Napoleon Hill and
started to listen to like a lot of stuff
that they like said in their books and
they went back and like started
listening to I listen to when your radio
those oh my god like he's saying the
same exact thing that they're saying
interesting he's just saying it
differently so it's cool for you like
your whole like your mindset theme that
you have about like owning the Jets yes
Napoleon Hill actually talks about that
in his book Think and Grow Rich because
you have that undying focus yeah for
that and that thing you do that's that's
the concept that you probably didn't
even know yet you had but even really
that's just in my dear I go ahead for
your husband um so firmly hasn't he um
he didn't grow up with the whole lot of
structure or soft
okay so his main tip that he would want
to know is having grown up with no
discipline in having no very little
self-discipline as an adult is there a
way that he can I guess learn to acquire
that self-discipline as an adult well
what's the discipline in um just in
general I mean he he wants big dreams
but is not worth the yeah he's full of
[ __ ] yeah in a lot of ways well let's
get him on the show let me get a crack
at it I mean you know it's it's it's
about you you have a very very tricky
spot in this relationship because you
love them and even the way you're
delivering it it's not like the it I can
see that it's not like the worst you
just want something good to happen so
you have to find the balance of not
actually perpetuating it by over
coddling him and entitling him at the
same token telling him constantly like
you also do something about it is gonna
hurt feelings so it's a you know it's a
tricky game you know my big thing is
that one of the things that I love to
tell people is like yo this is simply
about you know results or results like
everyone everyone has excuses so Jessica
Felice says here I've major different
problems like lol like here's the
reality and this is a really good cold
this isn't this isn't a tea this is this
isn't even a dirty tea this is ice cold
tea for everybody this morning the
results are always right what I mean by
that is if you're not winning it is 100%
your fault not 99 not 98 not your mom's
not you're not the system's not this one
deal fell through not oh God Korona
happened now 100 percent is your fault
and I think people that lack discipline
or talk about big game but never do [ __ ]
need to be reminded 24/7 365 sometimes
cold sometimes sweet tea but they need
to be delivered every single time 100
percent of this is on you oh you haven't
achieved that thing yet that's you
that's you not the neighborhood not how
I grew up like oh I grew up
undisciplined like that's called excuses
many people grew up with [ __ ] family
situations in [ __ ] hood with drug moms
and all that [ __ ] and went on to [ __ ]
do [ __ ] because they had thank God for
them the DNA the serendipity they met
somebody along the way that honestly in
a lot of ways that is what drives the
[ __ ] out of me it's Rihanna I want to be
that person because I had people around
me there's a level of gratitude and
guilt that makes me want to be the
person for people that they stumbled
across on YouTube or twitch or
what-have-you
that helped them get happier and
happiness starts with accountability
period and a story period and a story
like the end you know like America move
Sweden's [ __ ] fresh like you know
like like yeah you know you don't like
your your mom drags you down move no but
then I'll hurt her if you know no no no
no that's you making you every person
watching this right now is one every
person watching this right now has the
internet because that's where I am right
now if you have the internet you are
100% accountable and so you know the way
you could help him is never is suffocate
him sometimes with sweetness sometimes
with a little bitter herb of yo honey
that's you that's not Ron's fault from
work
that's not your dad's fault that he I
have no idea what the situation I'm just
giving thrown out like like this is a
hundred percent accountability yeah
nobody gives a [ __ ]
that you had an unstructured life
definitely not your dreams your dreams
don't give a [ __ ] that you had an
unstructured life if you got [ __ ]
dreams if you're talking big game go
[ __ ] execute don't tell me why you
can't execute excuses are some
complaining and excuses or [ __ ]
poison gar
using DNA suffered easily I'm trying as
much as I can
yeah exactly but but why I'm saying
sweet and and candor you got to mix it
because suffocating means every time it
gets brought up you don't let it go by
guys no yes ma'am
can't be the yes woman you got to be no
but sometimes like sometimes it's like
honey you're [ __ ] full of [ __ ] and
you walk out of the room that's other
times it's like baby I know that you
[ __ ] didn't have it like that as a
kid but the punchline is there is no
time machines you can't go back so if
you're gonna [ __ ] go do all these
things you got to do it now that's sweet
you know something something like you
got but but never yeah you're right
anytime you say yeah you're right to a
complainer and a dweller
you're [ __ ] feeding the beast okay
you're enabling you're nailing that
[ __ ] yeah or me never get you're
right
never just ignore it it's always
suffocating something is suffocating
mm-hmm all right good I will do that
awesome Morgana King take care public
address cutie
that was good I'm into that [ __ ] Dustin
I believe in that [ __ ] bro yeah that's
something me and my girlfriend actually
working on all the time just uh not
feeding each other like not enabling bad
behavior yeah yep let's keep it going
what's up my man what's up hey it's um
remember me but I was the guy that
tweeted you that I was driving my
wheelchair up to new birth to your hands
and I just thank you for what you've
done for me in the pan and like you do
for me my question is I've done
everything you told me to do on tik-tok
on Linc
not LinkedIn but Instagram and Twitter
and I'm in the process of writing a book
and I don't know and I'm gonna have the
clothing brand is my car I donated a
clothing brand I just don't know what
the next step is to go go go further
take it to the next step like I've
reached out to like like thinner
speakers to try to do like get more
speaking games because I've been doing
that a lot and I just don't know what
the next step is for me too
when you say next step what are you
trying to accomplish like make the book
sell or or get speaking it like what's
the what's the ROI of the book sells I
just want to do it then just spread the
message yeah I mean you're gonna stick
with me here this is an important moment
I think this will bring you value the
message will find its audience over time
all you can do is put it out when I say
post everywhere all I'm really saying is
put out your story put out your message
and then what ends up happening bow is
the market takes over okay
I mean there's been people who wrote
books in the 40s and 20s that didn't get
fame until they were dead in the 70s
because somebody read it and put it on
yeah more of my videos will be consumed
after I'm dead then when I'm alive yeah
you see where I'm going if you're
actually telling the truth that you just
want to spread the message which is my
truth then you just spread the message
most people are actually are trying to
make as much money as possible get as
much fame as possible they're going
selfish not selfless when you go [ __ ]
selfless you have no anxiety yeah I've
never thought about it when it wasn't
happening it didn't cross my [ __ ] mind
yeah and like like you said living your
truth like I know I'm I know I'm in a
wheelchair I'm not gonna get a
wheelchair at all and I'm happier I mean
I was they're not happy about it but
it's my that's right yeah and then and
then like the whole exception vs.
reality thing you know like give a thing
I'm so depressed about being a
wheelchair it's no I know you're not
it's me it's why it's why I love you
it's why I know you can win but I don't
want you to get caught up in [ __ ]
metrics of money and followers if you
just you just need to keep [ __ ] making
content bro yeah it's just not you it's
just not doing as well as you wanted to
do exactly but like like paying for
stuff like I'm gonna like I wanna like
get on my wheelchair okay well guess
what I'm buying new lights for your
wheelchair really yeah thank you you're
welcome
you and Dustin gonna connect right now
you're gonna send me your PayPal and I'm
gonna send you 700 bucks and now you got
[ __ ] lights on your wheelchair okay
now you can go spread your message okay
so do that with their abilities can you
knit okay have you thought about
flipping I literally no no no no no I'm
talking Internet only internet only like
anything obviously you know I think
about sports cards anything buy
something buy something for 25 bucks
repost it for 45 bucks I mean have you
thought about it I've done that I've
done that but they closed the the the
Salvation Army close to me so I can only
remember what I said Bo no no internet
only buy something you know buy a lot of
wrestling figures on eBay you get them
home sell them off individually make the
hundred percent profit okay I think you
can do that Bo I think you can really
get good at that yeah to do well listen
to me I know I know that you want more
people to follow you more people to see
[ __ ] it can happen if you just keep
going at it and if your message is good
enough if it's not it won't that's just
the truth
so one of the things that people need to
worry about is changing up their message
a little bit I don't think most people
are going deep enough I think most
people go surface-level see I'm trying
to go deep too because you say you know
putting out content and look you know
that stuff I want you to go deep my
right I want to go deep on every
platform yeah I'm trying to that's what
I'm trying to do listen it's a it's a
long game bro yeah it just is and you
started like obviously just started off
and you know saw these shirts and stuff
and and that kind of stuff and you know
I don't know I just need like give me a
shot well good I'm always here couple
things
this was super productive first of all a
fuckload of people are probably
following you right now on Instagram and
Twitter let's see what's going on there
yeah that's good that'll give you a
boost of the arm I'm here for listen I'm
all about boosts in the arm I love
giving boosts in the arm like I'm here
to give you a boost in an arm right so
let's there's that right so here's a big
one I didn't even realize this I've been
followed you yet so boom you just got my
fall that's [ __ ] matters right that's
nice you're at 8:43
you're at 8:46 I don't know what you
started at when you got on here well
good you're about to get over a thousand
watch this here comes the vaynernation
everyone's gonna come hard and as soon
as now that they see you're smiling this
shit's gonna get real crazy every [ __ ]
on here is about to follow you so that's
good that's a little boost in the arm
another boost of the arm is I just
bought you [ __ ] lights for the
wheelchair you're [ __ ] now we got
[ __ ] lights
that's [ __ ] huge because I dropped my
wheelchair I've literally dropped my
wheelchair like like like I've given a
thousand miles in over a thousand miles
in six months yeah and we can't get you
need [ __ ] lights we can't get you
can't be dangerous out there
no we can't no so now you're [ __ ] now
you got lights right so that's good so
here's the booster yard you got lights
yeah you're gonna send me the link and
you're you're gonna give Dustin the link
to where you want which lights you want
and your PayPal right yeah
actually so then so then so then I'll
just wired
700 bucks on PayPal okay okay so that
will get done right after this code like
you'll talk to Dustin so that's good you
know what another boost is look at this
look at this bow yeah 1100 what's that
coming in like I figure you're on the
phone right now you're getting all the
push notifications yes that feels good
right that's a little door fin hit for
the [ __ ] bow this morning very good
yeah bro I'm gonna beat your [ __ ]
brings it no you know me you don't know
me I'm not gonna hold back I don't give
a [ __ ] about anything I'm gonna beat
your [ __ ] stole it we'll see we'll
see bo you better you better you could
bring a friend too and cap three hands
I'm gonna beat the [ __ ] of both of
you I'm not losing you and [ __ ] ice
hockey for Nintendo I don't give a [ __ ]
bow my brain won't let me lose to you
okay all right I'll see you on twitch
talk to Dustin will get you the lights
congratulations on all your new
followers and remember slow and steady
on those wheels brother it's gonna take
some time don't get down day by day day
by day yeah and you know I'm just trying
to do the next step you know I really
wanna you know do it do it and I feel
you know I sell patience for free like
it's patience bro you just started yeah
and there's gonna be a huge boost a
bunch of people probably DMing you right
now with opportunities so take up all
those people that want do podcasts and
collaborations use this as a springboard
moment for you you got lights and you
got [ __ ] a boost on your Instagram
and that's gonna get you going yeah yeah
and then I can go from there
thank you kids you're welcome brother
talk to you soon let's keep it going
yep yep Dustin yep
they don't realize that I would I would
be Bo 12 to nothing and I saw seeing
that this let's stand up and go get
right in his face I got when I go into
competition Gary that's a different
[ __ ] dude I know you've seen it yeah
when they will see it the most what's
your favorite competition Gary story I
remember you're in the twitch studio and
you're playing I don't never what game
you were playing but it said that one
photo we posted of you were either like
Oh going nuts like my arms looked huge
it was like I think I asked if we think
enhance them all fired up yeah all right
let's keep going honey no I'm good thank
you it was still great what you did with
vous I love that um I visualized this
moment over and over in its king so
thank you so much for having me
you're making this the best day of my
life I'm sure I am actually stuck and
I'm feel like I'm missing a piece of the
puzzle so that's why I'm here with you
and I wrote down a few notes just to
give you really short background and
then I'll ask my question so about three
and a half years ago I quit corporate
and I hated every minute of it but I did
it because I really wanted to experience
I like the money I like the car I liked
all the benefits but in my heart and
blood and soul I'm just a real
entrepreneur and and I just want to be
location independent and travel the
world I've been living abroad for many
many years but I never ever take the
leap of faith I don't believe in that so
I just work work work so before I left
them before I quit I really started
building what you call leverage and
credibility and all of that so meanwhile
while I'm here now I published books I
co-authored book I did two TEDx talks I
have a bunch of online courses on udemy
I started really focusing on YouTube but
all my content there and I coach you
through clients but I also have a
teaching job at university part-time
because I need the Paycheck get it smart
so your practical and ambitious yes but
I have to say I have to add that I used
to be super shy low low low
self-confidence and I taught myself
everything so that's the message I want
to bring out in my youtube content
everything is like you guys you can
learn it you know you can learn this I
was like yeah yeah everything that you
talked about the mind said that you know
the positivity I created this life for
me I'm able to travel not because I'm
lucky no because I created because my
parents create my reality yeah there's a
lock their circumstances and execution
there's no goodly absolutely luck is a
loser word there's circumstances and
there's you know execution now of course
you know you know of course there's
circumstance and maybe luck and
circumstances are
same word but like no question like you
can make so much happy happen for
yourself and if you're defeated by it's
already been written then you're not
gonna do anything Emily and I stopped
comparing myself to other people because
you get you know you you look at the
others like oh do you have it all I
don't have anything and you stay so you
don't know anything about them they may
exact all on paper you have you said you
had the house the cars but you weren't
happy [ __ ] that no I want to know what
their souls about yeah absolutely and so
that's really what I want to do at least
like I just I just want to continue my
life living a life without regrets but
also inspiring people to hey don't stay
stuck in a job that you hate and just do
what you love and live that life without
regret so I just my drive is like I
don't want to grow old and thinking ah
what if I had done it you know no I
don't want to be that person so I want
to live so my question is well first of
all I could use you love to boost I
would love to have your boost on my
youtube channel because I don't know put
all my content there you know so much
Dustin thank you Gary and my question
really is what am I missing here how can
i monetize this more so that I can quit
that teaching job you know and just be
fully my own boss and just Wow all of
that content I give give give but I'm
not monetizing are you asking not enough
I knew you were gonna say that but I
just it's it's cuz because I'm listening
to you you know everyone's always like
how are you talk over buddy I'm [ __ ]
listening if you started from a place of
insecurity the number one place where
people are insecure is the ask yeah you
might have dressed a lot of areas the
next place we need to boost up is your
ability to feel confident for the ask
cuz I mean I I post I share I you know I
give value and I know I mean I have
coaching clients I know I'm good at this
because they always say I will never
deliver I have you have to ask more and
you have to charge more hmm it's just
practice what's amazing is I know you're
gonna do it because you've already done
the first part this is literally just
asking for more
how much do you how much if I asked you
right now - if I was Johnny Magoo and I
said I want you to be my coach what
would be the price way too low about you
thinking about about fifteen hundred
dollars for four months right so
a little less than $400 a month mm-hmm
wait so now make it five now the next
person that asks make it $2,000 for four
months now that's 500 the next person
600 the next person 700 and then and
then what you'll learn is people said
yes all day long at 500 they said yes
all day long at 600 but at 700 you you
know you're getting pushed back only
half say yes that's still good at 800
everyone says no good news
you found your market you're about 750
but not when one person says no when 20
people say now and so you need to push
the envelope of your cost and then on
your content you need to ask more often
and say hey everybody I'm taking on five
more clients today this is the video
it's not gonna get as many likes or as
many views cuz it's a sell but you mean
like today I'm taking on five more
clients let me tell you why I think I'm
great let me maybe you take a video and
do a zoom with three people that use you
as a coach and put the testimonial in
there and then you sell five people Jab
Jab Jab right hook you have to be okay
with asking especially when you believe
in it you've heard this for me like the
reason I give my texts right now today
we're selling a $95 Cabernet that got 95
points from the best wine magazine for
$39 when wine calm is selling it for $95
when Vivino selling it for $104 of
course I'm gonna tell you
everybody's got Father's Day coming up
they could buy something for $39 that is
$100 value like of course I feel good
about throwing that right hook and you
feel good about you being good yeah I
know I'm good it's just that I do I mean
I feel like I want to put more energy
into this and I just but I I mean people
are not really asking me for coaching
y'all I guess because I'm nice that's
right you're like a gentleman yes like
you have to make them aware that you're
open for business like it's okay
and it's okay when you go for it and and
nobody orders it - you're like okay Gary
got me hyped yury watch the video you
put on some rocky music and you go in
and nobody buys that's okay - you go
right back to providing value so many of
you you're just asking posts just asking
post like that or and yep okay
just be my client and grab your coaching
session and make make make a video you
know once a month and say this is the
you know every month as you guys know
like literally
literally you know tomorrow you're like
hey guys it's Rachel again you know like
every month going forward one one of my
youtube videos is gonna be about signing
up some coaching clients cuz I'm really
excited about it and I'm gonna point in
my life it's just transparency right
Rach I'm just gonna act as you right now
and you got some of you may or may not
know I'm gonna put in my life where I've
got another job as well and I'm on the
verge of being full coach and I want to
give more energy to my coaching clients
and if I tip over and get another ten
clients I can do that so I'm doing a
special today like I'm you know spoke to
Gary Vee the other day and I may be
raising my prices but for anybody who
signs up now I'm gonna honor my
retroactive price next month I'm gonna
be in my new pricing I really feel proud
of it if you want to speak to some of my
clients when you email me you know -
I've asked all seven of them two of them
said yes they'd be references you're
happy to talk to them but I'm telling
you right now I really believe that the
investment you make with me will be ROI
positive for you and so a couple other
things which I think you should go to
six months four months it's just it's
yeah yeah I just gave an example but I
have like different packages yeah yeah
yeah I would have six your floor your
floor okay I'm sure where I'm going I
would make six your floor just because
it gives you more time to make an impact
totally it helps you know four months
takes a month to get kind of cozy you
know by the time you're going you're
you're in that renewal cycle which for
you comes for in on the sales so I want
to give you a little more time to
breathe this is [ __ ] business
strategy yeah true I do YouTube my
YouTube videos are all about you know
tips and advice on gaining clarity and
the confidence and the mindset and
overcoming fears but what you just said
is it more like a live or something do
more alive oh okay by the way yes live
and YouTube video like for one day your
salesman Rachel okay it doesn't have to
be alive that's what you're saying it's
gonna be both I want you to go alive I
want you to go out yeah like the 15th of
the month every day you do selling your
coaching it's fine
yeah I do I look live to now but yeah I
want to do I want I want it your if you
choose your number one platform you have
to go there if you have an email service
email that out there like we call it a
launch on Team Gary like if I'm like hey
we're launches that means everybody's
getting hit every channel
email text platform social
yeah and I have enough things to sell at
my online course is my books I mean I
yeah but I just yeah ask ASCAP you need
one Saturday selling Saturday selling
Sunday one day a week one day a month
excuse me where you just sell and that's
ok maybe you go on live for eight hours
and answer QA and the whole time you're
selling like you need a sell day yeah
makes sense yeah got it
yeah can I have twenty seconds because I
really want to shout out my little
brother he's amazing I miss him and I
love him to bits and he's a barber and
he just fits such an amazing content on
his Instagram and so he's Instagram
handle his barbershop Reginald and he's
just really Travis how do you get
settled uh have you spoken old ar e ji
an Ald Reginald barber shop barber shop
Reginald thank you so much you're
welcome oh wow thank you so much Gary
you're welcome bye bye see that was a
cell she sold her brother's profile
she's got it in her let's keep it going
Gary what's going on man what's good
Nick what are you from I'm from Topeka
Kansas that's what's up
hey man I just wanted to say thank you
and to let you know that this moment
makes me extremely happy man
I feel super honored to be on your show
and if I could get a virtual cheers for
my birthday are you 2229 appreciate that
looking good bro thank you so my
question here I really had to but so I
work insurance right now and the first
question I have is how can I bring value
in and as a consumer for you Gary at
what would you say on this how can I
bring value without coming across as a
salesman one more time how do you bring
value as two other people - then do
business with you yes by watching what I
do right like there's a lot of people
who buy the
why now for my dad's store from empathy
wines because I bring them value at all
times and then occasionally I mentioned
what I do or what I'm passionate about
right so the way you bring value without
being too Sally is by not being Sally
right but but also like the last lady
being okay with asking for the sale once
in a while so you put out as much
content whether it's about Kansas
whether it's about eSports whether it's
about insurance whether it's about you
know beard culture you get people to
know you
I'm being serious though the beard your
beard might be the single reason you
sell the most insurance because nobody
you know yours is boring that's what I'm
saying like I know you're saying why do
you think there's Geico and progressive
like and the like flow and like Snoopy
for MetLife insurance is so [ __ ]
boring they have to create the
characters right and I don't want to do
like what you've said in an interview
before is like I don't want to sell fear
you know that's one reason like you said
that you wouldn't sell insurance is
because of like how you sell it you know
well I would sell practicality though
you know some people are like what if he
dies him that's fear but if you're like
hey listen unfortunately as we all know
one day something will happen and it's
nice to have this in place right mm-hm
you see room you see where I'm going
right and good okay and so I don't want
to interrupt you but they're not
attacking me so the second question
really is um how does someone find their
passion by tasting things like how do
you know if you love surfing if you've
never [ __ ] surfed mm-hmm listen to
other times say that man inside I
figured that would be your answer so let
me ask you a question to make it even
more valuable to your brother what do
you think might be your path if I'm like
yo bro
thirty days you're just gonna do thirty
different things like what are some of
the things that come to mind I mean
music I love cooking
have you ever made a video on youtube of
you cooking something not like a video
but like I've posts
like what I've cooked what about a video
why don't you make a video tonight take
your phone set it up and cook and put it
and post it on YouTube and post it on IG
TV and see what the [ __ ] happens okay
that's actually how you do it brother
right and I've been I've been working on
that like I mean that's why I'm on this
video right now like I will admit like
its its execution like you're absolutely
right oh and you you posted twice about
T with javi yesterday I said hey man
like it's my birthday can I get on I
didn't hear anything and like I really
wanted to talk to you and get these
things answered so I asked again and
that's when you hit me yeah and I happen
to see it and that was that's rare yeah
me probably watching right now I've
asked me 4,700 times to be on TV with
Carrie B it's all serendipity but if you
didn't if you didn't ask the second time
I wouldn't have seen the tweet and we
wouldn't have this moment right now
throughout its execution it's always
execution everybody plays out life in
their brain instead of with their hands
and their legs
uh-huh [ __ ] you have to do it's only
doing everything the plays in the head
is all insecurities and and [ __ ]
[ __ ] you got to take [ __ ]
positive thoughts and put them to action
it all comes down to not giving a [ __ ]
what people think so I spend so much
time on it you know it's being strong
enough to put up that cooking video and
being okay with people in your life
texting you me like what the [ __ ] are
you doing
if you then reply to what the [ __ ] are
you doing get the [ __ ] out of my [ __ ]
cooking YouTube video you worry about
you mom mm-hmm you worry about you Rick
you worry about you boyfriend like what
do you mean what I'm doing I'm living my
[ __ ] life what the [ __ ] are you do it
and I for everybody who's watching right
now when you do something cuz you get
inspired right now and do something new
and somebody goes what the [ __ ] are you
doing
reply with ease what do you mean what
the [ __ ] am i doing I'm doing what I
want to do what the [ __ ] are you doing
get out of my [ __ ] life it's crazy
you say that cuz I put a Facebook post
that said if you haven't asked me for
insurance period delete me and like
coming from me like that people they're
like me and you're so full like what's
going on like what's up hey man him and
I'm and so but I did I followed it up
with love the next day I was like listen
I hit you too much with the right hook
like I haven't even brought any value
you know and I tried to make myself
accountable by saying like hey listen I
am gonna bring you value I haven't yet
so um you know I hear you gay I listen
to you and I really appreciate you
having me on here and I'm gonna start
doing man I I just had it and this year
congratulations
and I gotta teach him the right way I'm
in teaching the right way is just about
love like you teach him love and
kindness you'll teach him the right way
if you want to build on top of that
these this is all gravy you know if he's
happy and he's kind you've taught him
the right way that's simple layering
some of this [ __ ] about business and
execution and and fulfillment that gets
a little bit too 201 301 that's that
next level right so you know I think I
think you got a shot I think you need to
absolutely just execute yeah just keep
build on this momentum REE watch this
video as much as you have to I will win
absolutely thank you so much thank you
you got it Omar Gary
oh my god man thank you for having them
I tried that we ate it like six times
over the last two it though I think
again they can speak me
you could speak you're doing great
brother are you from I'm from Egypt
Egypt very nice
I met him the first one for me to hop in
this show I think you might be I'm
trying to think but I think you might be
it's a real upset it records it well
thank you okay let me give you some
context and water my question is all
right first of all woman thank you man I
got agree Oh like a picture of you
hanging on a menu you changed my life
can you imagine that right so let me
give me some context right so I'm a 16
year old seventy is to be 17 right okay
and I create content I've been creating
like different stuff and my main thing
is I wanted people to get a perspective
you know what I'm saying I learned from
you and you want to implement that here
in like the whole like from my community
my community and then grow up you know
I'm saying yes so I'm I'm always I'm
trying boost like 30 times a day am i
have to LinkedIn a half tone sick though
I'm doing everything I'm hustling I'm
like I'm trying my best a nice I how I
know there's like stuff that I saw most
luminous so that I'm gonna do about like
I'm in the process right but my problem
is I'm not gonna give like sugarcoat it
my problem is I'm not patient enough
mm-hm like and I don't want it to like
stick it and say oh we all know I'm down
things so I like help Orton I like I
don't care about judgment I don't listen
to I got people happen on my videos say
yo shut the [ __ ] up and just go play
playstation whatever well like I'm in my
zone and I'm i try i'm gonna i'm i'm
gonna give people content and i'm gonna
do it i don't care what y'all say right
but I won I won dad faith let not the
fame I don't keep him I want the impact
the notoriety the nhf yet like I wanna
leave all of it the energy right Smith
yeah right I want everything I want
people hopping in my name's asking me
stuff I want to be in the game you don't
I'm saying not gonna hurt it you haven't
earned it yet you're right but like Matt
not ask that's what I'm stuck at like I
I want to be six foot four and throw a
football 800 yards like and when 10
Super Bowls is the quarterback instead
of the owner like I understand wanting
you have an early
qingxue yongsan i that's fantastic
that's I want you to think I think
you're gonna win the whole thing if you
can make one little switch if you
realized working for all of it tastes
better than all of it your whole game
will click you just reminded me of this
verse from any lifted hippo so it's like
you know from Jay Cole of yours it's
like building the struggle me just
reminding me I'm that way saying it's
bro it's what it is
yeah I get that I gave that I think
tonight can I tell you something yeah go
in I think you're gonna look back at
this in 15 years when you have it and
you're gonna realize this was the best
part not that you have it I swear on my
[ __ ] soul when I didn't have it but I
knew I was gonna get it felt a lot
better than this feels right now so when
you were like in 2080 and working in the
liquor store I liked being
underestimated
I liked people not knowing yet but the
problem is like when I think about it
like look you get like I can be take
like I'm 17 and I'm healthy and own
things and I like it could be taken in
any moment and I would leave with no
legacy I don't care about the legacy did
someone call you but you're but you're
being you're being ideological oh my
gosh someone just said what's your
instinct I'm on in the image man I'm
gonna be famous listen to me well you
know you're going what is your Instagram
it's oh ma are sa LEM oh three Omar
Salaam o three
yes exactly awesome Omar listen to me
you are you you have no choice about
that though like to your point I
understand it you can be taken at any
moment if a tree decides to fall on your
head tomorrow the punch line is that's
what it's gonna be you have no control
over that you being impatient is gonna
make it more likely that you won't get
what you want
so you're [ __ ] worried about
lightning striking than something that's
almost impossible by reacting to that
what's something that's guaranteeing ly
not gonna get you what you want so
you've decided on some math that is
almost impossible I might die which is
very rare for a sixteen going on
seventeen year old
I might die and then I didn't leave my
impact so you because you've put that in
your mind as a perspective you're gonna
be impatient and come off as not as good
of a version as view okay I hear you
but like let me listen like the counter
when I think about that because it moves
me something like when if I told myself
you're like I'm gonna live like for 100
years I don't think I'm gonna be
motivated nope I don't agree with you I
think I'm gonna live for a hundred years
I'm motivators [ __ ] why do they have to
be counter feelings you can carry both
of those I've got good news for you I
already know that you're gonna be
motivated regardless of what you decide
cuz you are motivated I am I am and I'll
be bobbum oh yeah the other part matters
just as much your ambition and hunger
and motivation if not offset by
practicality patience and execution will
fall on deaf ears and lead to
unhappiness I'm with you and all that
but like patience is just oh I'm working
on it I'm really let me let me shoot you
straight brother in a real like straight
canvas way you're more interested in the
fame than the process of the fame and as
soon as you realize that things will get
better I am yes that's true but I know
it's a period period from our period all
right we can put a semicolon and they go
no I'm not kidding I'm not giving you
that extra little dot because you're
gonna get caught if you put the [ __ ]
admiration on a pedestal greater than
the process to get the admiration you
will limit the upside of the admiration
period like I don't really care about
the image I just care about impacting
people I want to look at my 15 years
from now I want to be the host of deal
with Omer and I'm helping people and I'm
giving I'm gonna be in the position news
I wanted to at 16 - and I got there by
working my [ __ ] dick off yeah I know
I'm right good news me too
here you go 28 years from now you're
looking at him the problem is I put in
the [ __ ] work
promising it I believe you cuz you have
no [ __ ] choice you understand that's
what's fun about this I'm not giving you
advice I'm gonna giving you the truth
you have no choice if you don't live
life come up with scenarios articulate
them in your mind figure out how to be a
communicator of them continue to say
creative if you're not the kind of
person that realizes oh I did this ad
for [ __ ] you know line text and it
worked so now I'm gonna try it on my own
content Oh weird it did better than most
of my other like if you're not creative
if you're not I really like that if
you're not patient if you're not like
like good news it doesn't matter what
happens here for what I say what you say
if you don't actually put in the work if
you don't actually execute it it won't
happen anyway it doesn't matter what you
want everybody want that's you I'll
execute I'm executing no no but but the
more that you realize that right now
that you're spending more time thinking
about you I spent no time I'm being dead
serious on this I need you to hear this
because it might help you and simply
gonna help others
I spent no time thinking about what this
was gonna feel like my like I can't
startling you know what I mean Omar I
I'd never think about I think about the
day I buy the Jets as the worst day of
my life not the best because you're on
the process you don't wonder correct and
I need you to I need you to take on some
of that you've already painted more
pictures of thinking what its gonna feel
like when you're at that place then I
did in my whole life so I'm trying to
say to you hey this might be something
that's worth debating not that I'm right
but hey this is something for you to
think about because everybody's laying
on their [ __ ] in their mind thinking
about what it would be like I think
about what it would be like to do the
work to get there I the work the process
they [ __ ] negative exactly like I'm
into that [ __ ] I'm into this like you
know like I like that I don't like the
yeah you've gone I like the getting beat
up nine rounds in and [ __ ] figuring
it out
I don't know if you watch my plight you
so sure
yeah I was looking I don't know if you
saw my video on Instagram about me doing
that plank challenge you need to go look
at that again ah yeah and they I wasn't
gonna come art only second your chopping
a little bit hoping this might hope okay
Omar
ah man return your good ish Omar listen
if you watch the plank challenge watch
it carefully early on I'm in real
trouble like I can tell she's gonna beat
me because I don't plank and you know
it's tired I hurt my back like I'm like
I was gonna no excuses she was gonna win
she was better handed and about three
minutes in two minutes in I I switched
it and I said to her Carolyn I been
joking this whole time this is hurting I
can do this for seven minutes
and it switched the moment it switched
the mindset and it put her in a spot
where she was stuck she was like [ __ ]
and it and and so in those two minutes
when I was in trouble I wasn't thinking
about what it would feel like if I had
won I was thinking about how am I gonna
win and so my mind went into a place of
like this who resonated really do you
understand yeah that's what I want for
you not to like a very very last move
I hope I'm not like taking so much what
would you say if there is one word or
like one thing that you can say every
single 16 or 17 at this age range person
on the planet patience it's all patience
everybody wants it now because they want
to use the clout of the thing to offset
all sorts of other things that are going
on Omar people want the clout to use the
leverage of the clout whether that is to
put a bandaid on their insecurities that
girls didn't like them or or to prove to
their dad who said they would never be
anything like they're just looking for
bandages of the cloud they're using the
clout to [ __ ] bandage I don't want
that I want people to
enjoy the process that's actual life you
know yeah you're chopping so we gotta go
okay love your brother it's too bad he's
really good talk sucks that the his
internet got jacked up but good [ __ ]
show today Dustin yeah you know speaking
of patience I've been very patient with
this audience Dustin I think what I'd
like to do is run the data and everybody
who commented today okay and if they're
not signed up for wine text if they live
in America and one of the states that
can ship - I think we should block them
from their ability of watching wine -
okay what about the underage people
underage is good people that live in
Michigan and Illinois and Texas good
people live outside of America but if
you live in New York New Jersey
California Florida Virginia and you
haven't signed up for wine tax and
you're over 21 and you're on here I want
to block them actually so let's get the
tech team involved let's get really
strict serious here big shout out to
Massachusetts you guys are in listen
today is the biggest day of them all
I would pre buy your Father's Day gift
right now $95 Cabernet for 39 bucks it's
ludicrous so it's a huge deal maybe the
best one that we've done yet please
please if you can't buy from wine Tech's
please share wine text now if you don't
drink like k-dubb here
let's put wine tax calm in your twitch
stream in your Facebook group in your
Facebook account in your Twitter text
your best wine friend you know let's do
that so love you guys
and sorry for everybody's getting
blocked we'll miss you if this was your
last episode of tea with Gary B live
we appreciate you you can watch the tape
versions but like it was great it's a
happy part of this community and what
you're about to see right now is a video
that we made I have started a new
Twitter channel where we're working on
something really cool and that's all
you're gonna be able to put the URL here
or actually everybody's watching right
now please as soon as the URL goes up
from this video type in the URL that's
clickable for all the people Jerry
Garcia you're good I know you're in
Texas so you won't get blocked but for
everybody who's getting blocked
miss you but let's uh let's check out
this the people that are gonna win over
the next five to seven years are gonna
be very comfortable and controlled
[ __ ] chaos the process rules require
sacrifice all your actions have to then
map back back back back back back nobody
gives a [ __ ] about where you grew up the
whole game and scaling the unscalable
it's [ __ ] hard work it's being
respectful it's being a good person who
that that's just a good idea it's there
the flipping is there this house right
here there's $400 of it I stay my lady
like real [ __ ] tight but you can't be
crippled everybody here's judging
themselves you're looking at what's in
front of you right now
you're losing cuz you're laying in your
bed looking at somebody's [ __ ]
glamorous photoshopped picture of them
doing something cool and you're envious
and you're jealous and you're impatient
and it's crippling you're upside let me
just say it one more time if you're
confused what I just said I say put your
[ __ ] flag on the ground up through
the [ __ ] you are whoever provides the
most value always you're entering the
greatest five year window of your life
my only answer today or any much like
it's just like try [ __ ] shut your
business down and go work for an apparel
company behaviour nobody you've ever met
got there without the hard work so you
better get your speed up you better work
harder you better work smarter you can't
Google stuff you're not gonna be able to
do anything that I'm telling
maybe my unical to check me out
hope you enjoy